france un échange de propos musclés à
l'assemblée nationale dans le cadre des
questions d'actualité une procédure qui
se déroulent tous les mercredis
aujourd'hui l'opposition s'en est pris
très vivement au premier ministre et au
ministre de l'éducation
quelques jours après la manifestation
réussie des partisans de l'enseignement
privé
jean-louis de seine l'ordre de passage
des questions d'actualité a donné raison
aujourd'hui à l'udf le rpr aura dû
attendre pour envoyer michel debré
maurice couve de murville au créneau
raymond barre plus modérée les a battu
d'une longueur pour interroger son
successeur votre loi est elle une étape
sur la voie qui mène à l'objectif
archaïque d'un grand service public
unifié et laïc de l'enseignement ou
conduit-elle à l'objectif d'une france
moderne d'un grand service national de
l'enseignement fondé sur le pluralisme
la liberté et la qualité
deuxièmement je vous demande monsieur le
premier ministre si le gouvernement est
prêt à accepter au sénat des amendements
suffisamment significatif pour permettre
aux dirigeants et aux parents d'élèves
l'enseignement privé de donner leur
accord un règlement équitable et durable
d'une malheureuse affaire que par pure
idéologie vous avait imprudemment
soulevé cette loi est donc une loi de
liberté et de tolérance
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement
continuera de la défendre devant le
parlement est de faire en sorte qu'elle
puisse entrer rapidement dans les faits
et pour apprécier la bonne foi et la
bonne volonté du gouvernement je
voudrais citer quelques chiffres
l'enseignement privé scolarise deux
millions d'enfants l'enseignement public
10 millions en 1980 les subventions
versées aux écoles privées
atteignez 11 milliards de francs cette
année la somme versée de 18 milliards
500 millions soit une augmentation de
68%
j'estime dont qu'un font penser effet au
gouvernement et que chacun s'en rendra
compte lorsque la loi sera mise en
oeuvre
l'udf a aussi pris de vitesse les autres
groupes pour la politique étrangère
tactique
elle avait invité la fille et le gendre
de madame sakharov dans les tribunes
longuement ovationnés par l'opposition
au grand dam des socialistes le groupe
communiste restants mais là aussi le
premier ministre a dû interrompre le
débat pour calmer les esprits mais avec
cinq interventions en une heure et demie
pierre mauroy cet après midi n'a pas été
à la fête
le comité